1981 c'est le début de cette histoire
sans fin et cette histoire qui m'amène
ici aujourd'hui pour vous parler de deux
sujets qui me passionnent énormément
l'alimentation et la conscience
j'aimerais partager avec vous comment je
suis arrivé à la conclusion de qu'ils
mangent et c'est aussi de la conscience
j'étais une enfant qui n'aimait pas
manger et je voulais depuis l'âge de 5
ans étudié les cerveaux et comprendre
les comportements humains
je me suis toujours intéressé est
fasciné par notre capacité de
s'améliorer en tant qu'individu
d'échanger et d'apprendre
j'ai toujours cru qu'on était
responsable de soi même et de sa vie et
je savait intuitivement que on devrait
participer activement dans la
construction de soi même de sa manière
d'être d'agir dès réagir et même des
gérer et que l'on récent mais toujours
est il qu'ils je n'éprouvais pas du
plaisir à manger je ne sentais pas faim
et j'avais des troubles digestifs assez
grave
j'ai grandi comme ça sans donner
vraiment trop d'importance en oubliant
assez souvent de manger mais en
subissant les conséquences tous des
mêmes
j'ai commencé très tôt ma vie
scientifique j'avais 16 ans quand j'ai
commencé à travailler en tant que
stagiaire dans un laboratoire de
recherche et je poursuivis depuis ma
carrière scientifique de manière
continue en passant par plusieurs
domaines tels que les maladies
tropicales
la génétique les cancers et finalement
mon objectif d'enfance les neurosciences
et plus précisément les comportements à
l'âge de 21 ans
je suis tombé malade vraiment malade
j'ai maigri 13 kilos en quelques mois
je n'arrivais ni à manger ni à boire
c'est comme si tout mon métabolisme
c'était complètement paralysé
j'étais hospitalisé pendant deux
semaines mais le médecin
du mal à donner un diagnostic mise à
part les constat évident que je n'avais
pas une mobilité normale du système
digestif
c'est à dire que le mouvement de muscles
responsables à faire passer la
nourriture la digérer et l'éliminer et
être au ralenti chez moi finalement ils
ont conclu que j'étais allergique au
gluten mais après quelques années de
régime strict j'avais toujours des
troubles digestifs
il n'y a pas très longtemps j'ai
découvert enfin que c'est que j'ai c'est
une forme atténuée d'une maladie
congénitale la maladie de riches tongs
cette condition fait qu'elle ait
ganglion nerveux que contrôle le
mouvement de tous les muscles du système
digestif plus précisément des intestins
et réduit chez moi cela entraîne un
problème des mouvements qui génère de
troubles digestifs assez grave et qui en
plus seront susceptibles d'avoir des
inflammations intestinales et à des
intolérances alimentaires
en gros tous les aliments dont la
digestion et plus à beaurieux zh
comme la vie les viandes et les aliments
crus sont incompatibles avec mon corps
et cela explique peut-être pourquoi je
ne les ai jamais apprécié finalement je
n'ai pas une enfant qu'à précieuse ni
même malade c'était juste mon corps qui
avait son mot à dire avant trois ans
quand j'étais déjà plus stable et un bon
état de santé
j'ai découvert une méthode est
spécialisée dans l'amélioration de la
performance et de la qualité de vie
l'été les puzzles qui la pièce qui
manquait à mon puzzle
cette méthode m'a permis dé développer
davantage la connaissance de soi
nécessaires pour travailler de manière
plus active sur moi-même et développer
mes capacités
la méthode de rose qui est plus connue
internationalement comme des roses m a
pour objectif de procurer un excellent
niveau de performances à travers une
préparation physique émotionnel et
mental mais aussi à travers le
développement des habitudes de vie
compatible et d'un raffinement du
comportement de sorte qu'on puisse
développer nos capacités au delà de
l'ordinaire cette méthode que je
pratique depuis 13 ans et qui j'enseigne
depuis huit ans m'a permis surtout de
faire le pont entre les savoirs et les
savoir faire
j'ai pu tester sur moi même les
connaissances acquises dans les domaines
scientifique et l'expérience empirique
procurés par les vécu de cette méthode
complète et cela a fait toute la
différence
mais peut-être que vous vous demandez
pourquoi je suis aussi fasciné par le
cerveau et par les comportements humains
notre cerveau est l'organe le plus
complexe et le plus fascinant
il est constitué des 86 milliards de
neurones et chaque mur elle peut faire
jusqu'à dix mille connexions dans
l'ensemble c'est la fait que nous avons
potentiellement plus de connexions dans
notre cerveau et des étoiles dans
l'univers avec les nombre astronomique
d'un million de milliards des connexions
possibles
cette machine complexe occupe seulement
2% de notre masse corporal mais consomme
environ 25% de toute notre énergie notre
cerveau est impliqué dans un absolu mans
tout ce que nous faisons
comment nous réfléchissons comment nous
sentons comment nous interagissons et
compte notre cerveau fonctionne bien et
est en bon état de santé
nous sommes bien et en bon état de santé
mais quand notre cerveau aller moindre
souci il est fort probable qu'ils nous
ayons de souci par ailleurs mais qui est
magnifique en ce qui concerne les
cerveaux c'est que il définit notre
comportement mais c'est qu'on nous
apprend pas c'est qu'un changeons notre
comportement on peut aussi remo délai
notre cerveau aujourd'hui il a des
techniques d'imagerie cérébrale tels que
la tomographie d'émission monophonique
connu comme suspecte
cal qui sont capable d'espionner
l'activité cérébrale tout en la
comparant avec un pattern d'activités
optimal
les psychiatres daniel hamel
il utilise cette technique il nous
montre de données étonnantes
il nous montre comment une mauvaise
alimentation
l'utilisation des drogues y compris de
la cigarette et des l'alcool même dé
manière modérée le manque d'activité
physique et de sommeil et même
l'habitude d'être toujours focalisé sur
ce que ne va pas ou ce qu'on ne veut pas
ou ceux dont on a peur peut réduire
notre niveau d'activité cérébrale et
nuire à son fonctionnement
mais d'après ses études
on a pu aussi identifier les facteurs
qui vont influencer positivement la
santé et la performance de notre cerveau
est ce que vous imaginez qu est ce que
pourrait être pour en citer quelques-uns
qui pour moi sont fondamentaux on
pourrait dire les connexions sociales
positives
l'apprentissage de nouvelles choses
la bonne quantité et qualité de sommeil
l'activité physique les sentiments de la
gratitude et le développement de la
capacité à être focalisé sur ce que l'on
veut et bien évidemment l'alimentation
le bon fonctionnement cérébral et la
bonne alimentation sont intimement liés
c'est 25% d'énergie dont notre cerveau a
besoin provient surtout de
l'alimentation nous pouvons donc choisir
de consommer les nôtres iman qui vont
permettre est assurée en fonctionnement
cérébral optimale ou les toxines qui
vont endommager des plus notre intestin
elle considérait comme en deuxième
cerveau il contient à peu près 100
millions de cellules nerveuses et à peu
près 20 types différents de neurones
c qui équivaut au cerveau dont chaque
instant est aussi directement lié
connecter à notre système limbique la
région de notre cerveau responsable pour
le contrôle de nos émotions
cela fait que l'un des sens est capable
de répondre fortement est
automatiquement à des états émotionnels
à l'insu de notre conscience et
réciproquement les fonctionnements de
longs instants qui est fortement
influencée par ces que l'on mange va
aussi à son tour influencer les
fonctionnement cérébral et même nos
états émotionnels les cerveaux est une
grande machine à traiter des
l'information et à générer des réponses
adaptées
mais les volumes d'information est
tellement grand tellement pourtant le
cerveau a besoin de simplifier ses
informations de les décortiquer pour
pouvoir les traiter plus facilement et
plus rapidement
la conséquence c'est que nous avons
d'une part développer une conscience
assez complexe mais d'autre part nous
avons aussi développé un regard ainsi
réducteur il tâte chic et déconnecté
vis-à-vis de nous-mêmes et du monde que
nous entoure pour un pour la nourriture
il en va de même
ilan à ce que voit dans la nourriture un
simple besoin physiologique souvent
dépourvus de plaisir d'autres utilisent
l'alimentation ou 12 ou se faire plaisir
en oubliant assez souvent qu'il en est
c'est que l'on mange mais pourtant la
nourriture n'est pas seulement notre
combustible qu'on m'a rien dit ma
collègue tout à l'heure les manger c'est
aussi une expérience sensorielle et
l'expérience sociale manger c'est aussi
de la conscience aujourd'hui
avec les valeurs et les rythmes des vies
que la société nous impose la plupart
des gens se sont déconnectés de leur
corps et leur nature de même là des
moments on n'était plus qu' on n'est ni
en vain et ce sont souvent les
expériences et les sensations extrêmes
tels que sauter des parachutes avoir un
dysfonctionnement quelconque du corps ou
même failli mourir qui nourrit une leaf
fortement avec notre corps ces
expériences nous permettent de réaliser
que nous sommes composés de plusieurs
dimensions bien connectée et qui
s'influencent mutuellement
c'est là le permet d'augmenter nos
perceptions et d'élargir notre
conscience mais est-ce qu'il faut
toujours en arriver là elle qu'il faut
toujours une situation extrême pour
devenir plus conscients pour changer
d'habitude je dirais que nous les
simples faits de s'observer et se donner
du temps pour soi d'entraîner pour
changer de vieux coons seulement des
vieilles habitudes même avant d'en avoir
besoin peut avoir les mêmes effets
certes avec un peu moins de drainer line
j'ai fait un grand changement des vies
quand j'ai commencé à observer davantage
à être plus à l écoute de moi même et à
travailler mon corps mes émotions et ma
tête de manière intelligente à travers
la méthode de rose je peux développer au
fur et à mesure ils conscience élargie
de mon corps à tel point de savoir c'est
donc qu'il a besoin etc dont il est
capable de gérer ou pas à chaque moment
donné j'arrive à réussir les
fonctionnements de mon corps presque
comme si je l'observais de l'intérieur
et cette conscience corporelle
c'est évidemment élargie à d'autres
niveaux notamment ce qui concerne le
comportement les relations humaines et
l'alimentation
aujourd'hui j'ai faim et je mange de
tout sauf les viandes de tout de suite
mais je sais exactement la quantité et
la fréquence de chaque élément que mon
corps est capable de métaboliser selon
chaque type d'aliments par exemple comme
j'ai du mal à digérer les aliments crus
tous les matins je bois de jus de fruits
mélangés avec des légumes et de feuilles
fait maison avec un extracteur de vue
cela nous permet d'avoir tous les
nutriments des aliments crus des manière
plaisante savoureuse et sans avoir à les
digérer ça c'est le plus important pour
moi est en fait si on pense et son
s'observe on constate que notre anatomie
digestive le dentaire n'est pas fait
pour déchirer de la viande crue sur deux
eaux comme le font les vrais carnivores
fait l'expérience souriez et regardez
vous entre vous faites l'expérience vous
allez voir qu'on n'est pas des grands
carnassiers
mais notre anatomie jesse fait n'est pas
fait non plus pour ma g de sel fibreuse
pendant des heures comme le font les
herbivores notre anatomie digestives et
dentaire est plutôt sec pour un régime
pâteux réduit en fibres facile à mâcher
et à digérer autrement dit notre
anatomie est fait pour de la nourriture
cuite et c'est exactement l'apparition
de la cuisson qui nous a permis
d'acquérir en gros cerveau avec un
cortex préfrontal très développé et qui
a fait de nous c'est que nous sommes en
fait c'est serré impossible d'avoir un
cerveau comme les nôtres sont les mots
jacques et de la nourriture crue parce
qu'on ne serait pas capable d'obtenir
suffisamment d'énergie pour nourrir ses
gros cerveau il est certes que la non
prix sont permet de maintenir les
nutriments des éléments de taille
mais la cuisson près du jer les aliments
pour nous et nous permet donc d'inviter
nière beaucoup plus d'énergie mais entre
l'alimentation et les cerveaux quelle
est la place pour la conscience
aujourd'hui il est encore difficile de
définir d'expliquer la conscience dans
tous ces niveaux scientifiquement nous
avons encore plus de questions que de
réponses mais nous savons que la
conscience est un phénomène
physiologique est fondamental comme les
temps le temps qui passe si je vous
demandais maintenant des m'expliquer de
me définir c'est qu'elle étend même si
on le sait tous intuitivement on peut
difficilement l'expliquer parce que le
temps qui passe est un concept
fondamental
ainsi que la conscience et notre
conscience elle est aussi liée au
traitement d'informations comme le fait
notre cerveau mais comme le font aussi
les ordinateurs mais jusqu'où j'essaie
les ordinateurs non pas une conscience
et pourquoi
souvent on utilise le terme conscience
comment synonyme de veille d'intellect
d'activité cognitives de raisonnement
mais ça ce n'est pas la définition des
consciences c'est un état de conscience
l'état mental la conscience n'est pas
simplement l'état d'éveil on né peut pas
en effet parler des consciences sans
parler du concept du soin et des
sentiments les soirs et les
protagonistes de sa propre existence
prêts à l'action et qui inspectent le
monde intérieur et extérieur à travers
ses perceptions et la perception c'est
un processus dynamique et interactif qui
nous fait vivre à tout moment en finn
antérieures dans lesquelles nous sommes
l'acteur principal là ces moments nous
sommes tous dans cette salle
elle en train de vivre une même histoire
pas vrai non chacun de nous dans son
monde intérieur j sa propre histoire
parce que chacun des protagonistes des
ses films un ordinateur n'a pas de soi
n'a pas des perceptions et donc pas de
conscience il a certaines régions du
cerveau qui ont été identifiés comme
étant nécessaire pour que la conscience
se produise comme par exemple les
pigments tomes dont le tronc cérébral
c'est cette partie juste derrière qui
lie notre cerveau avec notre colonie
notre moelle épinière c'est-à-dire qui
réduit les corps à la tête mais aussi
les thalamus qui est bien au centre de
notre cerveau et qui est liée aux
émotions
ensuite les cortex préfrontal la partie
tout en avant de notre cerveau et qui
est responsable pour c'est qu'on appelle
des mental ou d'esprit mais aussi les
claustras mêlant si l'accès aux sons
d'autres régions du cortex cérébral mais
tout porte à croire que ce qui est
vraiment important pour que la
conscience se produisent c'est la
connexion entre ces régions
c'est la connexion la communication
entre les neurones qui sous-tend
l'intégration de l'information
mais tout cela paraît très abstrait donc
on ne parle pas d'attention
la tension est un processus mental
nécessaire à la conscience lorsque l'on
porte notre attention vers quelque chose
on augmente cette connexion cérébrale
cette communication et on éveille notre
conscience vers cette chose lorsque l'on
parle de perception on pense à quoi on
pense à sensation un sentiment à éveil
des sens donc d'une manière plus
pragmatique on pourrait essayer de
résumer des dire que c'est d'une part on
travaille pour cultiver et élargit nos
perceptions sensorielles
extrait sensorielle et que d'autre part
on porte notre attention vers les moment
présent là on élargit naturellement
notre conscience et qu'est ce que cela a
à voir avec l'alimentation
la nourriture c'est que nous permet de
survivre de fonctionner mais ce n'est
qu'à ces moments là qu'on j'ai compris
l'aspect sensoriel est conscient de
l'alimentation je suis parvenu enfin à
attirer plaisir comme un bébé qui
découvrent la nourriture à travers les
cinq sens j'ai réalisé qu'ils mangeaient
n'était pas une obligation ni simplement
en maison physiologique mais que je
pouvais la savourer à travers les cinq
sens à travers les couleurs qui se
mélangent les goûts et les odeurs révèle
prélevés par des épices les sons et la
texture des aliments dans ma bouche et
dès que possible même la sensation
agréable démangeait avec mes mains en
prêtant attention j'ai réalisé qu'ils
mangent et c'est l'expérience
sensorielle riche présente naturellement
cela nous mène vers une alimentation
plus consciente
au delà de la saveur eu du plaisir on
veut choisir soigneusement sait qu'il va
par la suite constituer notre corps on
veut choisir son origine sa cohérence
avec notre mode de vie et notre éthique
sa valeur nutritionnelle son impact sur
notre santé et la santé de
l'environnement
j'aurais plus à vous dire mais comme on
n'a plus le temps
je vais finir avec une citation que j'ai
trouvé par hasard d'un scénariste
français appelé jacques jean marie
gourio et que je connaissais pas mais
qui m'a beaucoup plu il dit les manger
c'est beaucoup plus que du manger il
faut toujours faire attention à ces
clones rouge puisqu'il et manger c'est
aussi de l'amour
moi j'ai rajouté ray en disant qu'elle
ait mangé c'est aussi de la conscience
merci